If you're in reconciliation with your partner
and they are still having such blow up arguments,
throwing shit,
you're feeling the need to run away, to go to hotel.
There is no working on things.
He's not working on things.
This is the behavior he needs to change.
And it is the behavior that he is still falling back to
whenever his little feelings get too worked up.
This is literally a toddler having a tantrum,
you know what I'm saying?
He is just manipulating and taking advantage of your kind heart,
your willingness to be a normal fucking human
while he's incapable of being a normal fucking human.
Nobody has a right to start throwing things
and make you feel so fucking uncomfortable in your own home
that you have to go to hotel.
And then he's gonna rub it in your face
and tell you you're a fucking coward
and haha, now you gotta pay for a fucking hotel.
Like he will continue to do this as long as you allow it.
And I'm saying it with love.
I love you deeply,
I love you dearly.
I don't wanna see you going through this.
And I just want you to be very clear.
It's gonna keep happening as long as you keep participating.